when you think punk rock you don't
usually think public library but that's
where the linda linda is an all girl
nearly all teenage punk band burst onto
the scene almost one year ago their song
racist sexist boy became a viral
sensation for its feminist anti-hate
message and the linda linda's riot girl
spirit now the girls ages 11 14 15 and
17 are touring with their debut album
it's called growing up they're opening
up for punk band heroes and headlining
shows themselves they even made their
late night tv debut but only after these
students finished their homework anthony
mason visited the linda linda's before
band practice in los angeles
if you want to talk about one of the
most anticipated albums of the spring
you have to wait till the band gets home
from school
that's when sisters lucia and mila de la
garza
can you give me a little boy their
cousin eloise wong
check check and close friend bella
salazar become the linda lindas
[Music]
the all girl punk band with a sweet look
but ferocious sound
[Music]
at age 11 mila the youngest drives the
beat at 17 bella the oldest is still in
high school
their debut album is aptly titled
growing up
[Music]
the album was produced by lucian mila's
dad carlos de la garza a grammy-winning
producer and engineer who's worked with
paramore and best coast all the parents
of this foursome are artists writers or
designers we never like had the idea
that doing music or
being in a band was like completely out
of reach right i grew up going to punk
shows and
where it's just like
it's do it yourself and like anyone can
do it and they had support early on from
the female punk rock icons in bikini
kill sonic youth best coast and the yeah
yeah yes how did the band happen
well christian control from the dum-dum
girls invited us to be part of this kid
band that she was putting together for a
show called girl school la
and there we actually got to sing with
west coast and cairno which is
cool
yeah that's kind of where it started it
was 2018 and they had to come up with a
name there was cat food for grandma
there was cat food for grandma there was
the cactus people
there was little stuff there little
stuff there yeah there are also some
other really bad ones
[Music]
[Applause]
finally they found inspiration in a
movie about four girl musicians a
japanese indie film called linda linda
linda which actually has a korean
actress they do not in it
cool
and we saw the movie and we were just
like this is this is cool because that's
kind of like us the pandemic sadly would
provide the inspiration for the girl's
breakout song boy from school
came up to me and he told me that his
dad had told him to stay away from
chinese people because of the virus for
the band which identifies as
asian-american and latinx it was
upsetting
especially at our age you feel like you
can't do anything about it but you can
write a song about it i mean
that's what we did
[Music]
[Applause]
they performed racist sexist boy at a
little gig at a los angeles public
library
the video posted by the library now has
more than 4 million views on twitter
you were probably as surprised as
anybody
our dad would just periodically like
come into our room and he would open the
door to go like you guys are going viral
then you close the door and
just like go back into my video here
bella was at school and i had my phone
on the table and it just kept buzzing
and buzzing and buzzing and then i open
up my phone and i like click my
instagram and my whole feed is just like
the video of us
they had about 18 000 instagram
followers then now the linda lindas are
at more than a quarter of a million
and growing it was
kind of unbelievable to like
think that there were people behind
those numbers yeah yeah i think it's
really cool that we were able to let so
many people know that they're not alone
like people who have experienced things
like that yeah but it's also so sad that
so many people have
related to that
[Music]
earlier this month in l.a they opened
three straight nights in the wilton at
the wheelchair with jawbreaker and it's
like whoa
please welcome the incredible the linda
linders and they performed on the late
late show with james corden
with that has come notoriety or as the
girls call it rock ignition i louise got
recognized when she was walking to
school a woman in her car said i love
you
and um i love you i'm just walking to
when i heard i love you and i was like
oh hi hasn't created any sort of sense
of expectation of you in any way or you
don't put that on yourself we even like
deserve like all this attention that
we're getting yeah i kind of just wanted
to
take a hold of what we have and try to
turn it into
something i could do more with you know
what i mean have you given a lot of
thought to how you could do that i think
just like
keep
doing what matters to us you know
like
keep writing what we feel like needs to
be heard and keep just
doing what we feel like is important you
know yeah
and keep happy keep having fun
[Music]
[Applause]
where do we start let the gushing begin
they are so
they are so impressive i mean first of
all they're so sweet but they're
incredibly thoughtful almost
philosophical at times i mean you saw
mila is 11 years old wow uh but she
thinks very profoundly about everything
that's happened number one i love that
some jerky kid said something to her
they spurred that and listen the lyrics
are catchy racist sexist boy vlad talk
about something so it's interesting when
she says that you know she when you're a
child you can't do anything about
somebody saying that chinese people
bring the virus but you wrote a song
about it and in the lyrics of that song
it says we rebuild what you destroy
which i love i love anthony it's like
we're seeing in real time them blowing
up i love the braces yes i love they're
sitting there with their little juice
drinks and they're so wise beyond their
years yes as per usual i identify with
the father who noticed they were going
viral open the door you're going viral
you got to give a lot of credit to their
parents yes clearly they've exposed
these kids to music early on and they've
really helped them along the way they're
really impressive kids and that's kudos
didn't you like talking to them i love
talking to them because they have
thought so much about what's happened to
them yes you know and and that most of
all they just love music and you can see
it you know one of the things that was
also really cool is tom morello and flee
and so many people were loving what they
were doing and someone called it the
song that we need in 2021. john tower
said two minutes ago we got to go
talk about the linda linda thank you
anthony yes gushing continues